hi there today we're taking a look at
learning model based planning from
scratch by deepmind so as a recap what
is model based planning basically a
model also called an environment model
is just kind of a black box thing you
can imagine and where you have a state
of your current environment you put it
in there and you have an action that you
want to take you put it in there as well
and the environment model tells you what
the new state as prime here and possibly
also the new reward and for taking that
action is going to be so this of course
it's always good to have such an
environment model because you can use it
to plan ahead but the authors here
question how do you plan and propose a
new algorithm to learn this planning for
now people have mostly kind of
heuristics to plan either things like a
star search where we have a maze and we
want to go here then you kind of have a
heuristic say the distance between the
two points but there's kind of walls in
between so you try to go there but then
there's a wall and you you kind of
explore around it so these are kind of
the techniques that have existed so far
also we've seen stuff like Monte Carlo
tree search for alphago and other things
like this that are not really learned so
this kind of paper provides a mechanism
to learn how to plan using such a model
so basically they guys and an algorithm
or a framework you can say where they
have this more you see here this
schematic this schematic tells you that
you have this thing called a manager let
me just quickly bring up my comment
thingy thing
all right so you can see here there's
this kind of manager and this manager
can decide to imagine or act if it acts
then it simply takes kind of the current
state and all the things that happen so
far
and besides on an action to do in the
world and then it kind of trains on the
action like classic reinforcement
learning but if you decide to imagine it
can use its model of the world its
imagination model to perform an action
and see what would happen if it did that
action and it can then also use that
append that in the memory and use it to
further learn even though it didn't do
the action you can imagine what happens
so how can it imagine the authors in
particular propose different methods of
imagining this graph you see they're
both methods the first two methods
basically so here if every role is a
method of imagine and the first method a
one step imagining simply means you have
the current state of the world which is
the gray blob here and what you do is
you always go from the current state of
the world imagine one step ahead so
basically you select this state to
imagine from you imagine one step and if
you if you decide to not take an action
after that but imagine again because
maybe you're not sure yet what you want
to do so you want to imagine another
action and you would again go from this
initial state so this in the horizontal
direction is time and time internal time
basically you read again scroll from
this state imagine another action based
on it and so on imagine another action
until you're satisfied you've imagined
enough so you can actually take a real
world step in contrast the N step
strategy so these are hard-coded
strategies as you can as you can see
it's the the learned part is which
action should I take the hard-coded part
is where do I base this action all the N
step and strategy also selects the first
state at first imagines one action on
top of it but then always selects that
new imagined action so that you can see
here it selects this one to propose this
action and then it selects that imagined
action to propose yet another action so
you can see it kind of imagines a long
path into the future instead of many
paths just one step ahead and then
lastly this imagination 3 strategy is
basically the only one that's actually
kind of a learned strategy where the
manager can now propose any previously
imagined or real world state in order to
mention from so you always have the
current world's fate which is the first
node in the graph you selectively of
course at the beginning have no choice
you imagine an axe on top of it but then
you can select any of these two nodes to
imagine from and here again the first is
selected an action is imagined then you
have three nodes you can choose any of
those where you want to imagine the next
step and you're the thinnest example the
manager select this state right here and
try it and he decides to imagine another
action on top of it until it is
satisfied and can it actually go to plan
two to actually perform an action in the
real world so if you if you then decide
to do an action in the real world what
you want to what you can do is you can
take all of the things you've imagined
and use that so you see in this pathway
here
it flows back to the manager at some
point if the size okay I've imagined
enough then we can use all these
imagined steps in order to take a
real-world step and after the real word
step the entire thing starts again so
that's how it learns to plan especially
interesting of course is this this
imagination through strategy where it's
actually learned to to what it actually
learns to plan ahead so the model is
described in detail you look at in a
formal manner and then it already goes
over to experiments and there's this
kind of spaceship tasks where you have
to just pictures you have to get the
spaceship to move around stuff and
around this asteroid and get a reward so
you can see different imagination kind
of projective here in the top rope you
see the red ones is kind of executed
action similar ones are imagined once
and you see the tree is constructed so
first it takes an action right here just
without imagine anything imagine to one
step but then decides to take another
action it imagines two actions let's
decide and decide on a third one so what
can you see to the left and in this
picture you see the first action then it
imagines one action and decides to take
an action when the imagines two actions
and based on these imaginations I'm
going to guess fairly satisfied with the
one that's very close to the target and
you can then take an action so you see
it's pretty smart in that it sees that
the second imagined action is
fairly close to where it moves to do and
it doesn't need to imagine yet another
action that then actually hits the
target you can go over to performing the
action right away because the
imagination gives enough information so
these kind of things are pretty cool to
look at and check out the more
experiments if you want to know here is
a new more experiments in discrete mazes
they feature multiple goals they feature
the system optimizing not only for its
reward but also for kind of internal
costs having a budget for imagining and
optimizing not doing too many
imagination step the kind of on this
experiment the kind of things that box
in here is the fact that they didn't
actually use the full imagination tree
algorithm but the manager only selected
from what you can see here so act is act
yet natural action then sj0 is the kind
of first imagine state necessarily okay
is kind of the last imagined state so
basically you know if the d managed can
only choose between actually acting then
doing kind of this one step strategy and
then doing kind of this end step
strategy
and each step so we kind of limit the
later it can plan but i'm going to guess
that he did this because otherwise they
could have trained the model and it
seems a pretty reasonable simplification
to make in order to get this to work
also check out the papers you're going
to see how all of these different parts
are implemented of course you can guess
most of them our neural networks and
it's pretty standard so far and check
out for the additional experiment
they're pretty cool and see you next
time